visita que hizo ayer a la provincia dio
de sal presidente volodomir sellent que
especialmente a uno de los tres puertos
habilitados para comenzar esa
exportación del grano los 20 millones de
toneladas que tiene en este momento
ucrania almacenadas en diferentes partes
del país dijo que todo estaba listo
desde el punto de vista logístico y
militar para que estas exportaciones
pudieran empezar a hacer realidad sin
embargo están a la espera de las
noticias que lleguen de ese centro de
coordinación que se abrió la el pasado
miércoles en turquía y que estará
coordinado por las naciones unidas y que
coordina todo el proceso de exportación
del grano ellos también proveen esas
rutas seguras que deben seguir los
navíos sin embargo siguen en esa
coordinación con bosco y todavía no se
han definido exactamente cuáles serán
esos mecanismos específicos que deben
seguir estos barcos así que aquí están a
la espera de esa luz verde ellos habían
dicho que esperaban poder salir y que el
primer barco saliera a finales de la
semana sin embargo estamos a sábado
hay gente que todavía no cree que este
pacto puede hacerse realidad muchos no
confían en moscú sin embargo estamos a
la espera habían dado como plazo mañana
por lo menos el ministro de
infraestructura dijo que al final de la
semana así que en las próximas horas
deben haber algunas noticias